This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hello friends. We have just 10 days before season 3 starts. September 19th is the big day. The plan is a new episode every 9 days, and Sam is here keeping us all in task, and you're going to really enjoy the new shows we're working on. In the meantime, I literally have 10,000 tiny pocket sized notebooks at my house that have to package and ship along with a thousand D-shirts. This is all a result of a fantastic Kickstarter campaign, not complaining at all. It's great, but we're working day and night here at 99PI HQ.
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。大家好。距离第三季开始只有10天了。9月19日是个大日子。计划是每9天更新一期节目，萨姆在这里监督我们的进度，大家一定会喜欢我们正在制作的新节目。与此同时，我家里 literalmente 有一万个袖珍小笔记本需要打包寄出，还有一千件D恤。这全都要归功于一次棒极了的Kickstarter众筹活动，我一点也没有抱怨。这很棒，但我们在99PI总部夜以继日地工作。
So rather than reorder the feed with a repeat or make you wait another week and a half, I have a story from a radio show that I've only recently started listening to, but it's just great. It's called Backstory with the American History Guys. And it's just a highly enjoyable show and you don't even need to love history to enjoy it. You just need to be curious about the world around you and like stories about how it got that way, which I guess is the definition of history, but the point is I think you're
因此，与其用重播来打乱节目列表，或者让你们再等一个半星期，我带来了一个我最近才开始收听的广播节目的故事，但它实在太棒了。它叫做Backstory with the American History Guys。这是一个非常引人入胜的节目，你甚至不需要热爱历史就能享受它。你只需要对你周围的世界充满好奇，并且喜欢关于它是如何变成今天这样的故事，我想这就是历史的定义吧，但重点是我认为你会
going to like it. Since 99% of visible is obsessed with the things we build and what these things say about us, usually in indirect or abstract ways, I'm drawn to monuments because these are things we build that from the moment of their inception, they're desperately trying to tell you a story to give a place or a moment in time, significance and meaning. But that meaning that's infused in the concrete and stone can be slanted, hurtful, bigoted, maybe misguided or even misunderstood. Anyway, this is a story about a monument that I couldn't get out of my head the first
会喜欢的。既然99% Invisible沉迷于我们建造的东西以及这些东西对我们的意义，通常是通过间接或抽象的方式，我被纪念碑所吸引，因为这些是我们建造的东西，从它们诞生的那一刻起，它们就拼命地想告诉你一个故事，赋予一个地方或一个时间点以重要性和意义。但那种注入在混凝土和石头中的意义可能会带有偏见、伤害、狭隘，甚至是误导或误解。无论如何，这是一个关于一个纪念碑的故事，当我第一次在Backstory节目中听到它时，我就对它
time I heard it on the show backstory. One of the hosts of backstory, the 19th century century history guy Ed Ayers is going to take it from here. In the 1890s, the first decade of 20th century, the veterans in both the union and the Confederacy were dying off and their sons and daughters noticed that they better acknowledge their enormous sacrifices and began to kind of mania putting up monuments and towns and cities and villages all across the country. And even into the early 1930s people were still trying to nail down all the meanings of
脑海中挥之不去。Backstory的主持人之一，19世纪历史学家埃德·艾尔斯将从这里接手。在19世纪90年代和20世纪的第一个十年，北方联邦和南方邦联的退伍军人都逐渐离世，他们的子孙后代意识到他们最好承认这些巨大的牺牲，于是全国各地的城镇、城市和乡村掀起了一股疯狂竖立纪念碑的热潮。甚至直到20世纪30年代初，人们仍在努力通过纪念来厘清
this complicated Civil War by memorializing it. And one place with a memorialization of the Civil War was played out was at one of the places where the Civil War in some ways began. Harper's Ferry, West Virginia, where John Brown led his famous raid in 1859, a band of white and black abolitionists trying to inspire a slavery bellion. Today, there are two monuments there. One is a six-foot tall obelisk. It kind of looks like a miniature of Washington Monument. And that monument marks the original location of the old federal armory
这场复杂的内战的所有意义。而内战纪念活动上演的地方之一，正是内战在某种程度上开始的地方——西弗吉尼亚州的哈珀斯费里，1859年约翰·布朗在这里领导了他著名的突袭行动，一群白人和黑人废奴主义者试图引发一场奴隶起义。今天，那里有两个纪念碑。其中一个是六英尺高的方尖碑，看起来有点像华盛顿纪念碑的微缩版。那个纪念碑标志着老联邦军械库的原始位置
that was so important in John Brown's raid. Today, across the street, maybe a hundred feet away, up against the side of a large brick building, is another memorial. And that one looks like a big tombstone, frankly, about the size of a refrigerator. It's a large granite and scribed monument. This is Todd Bolton. He works for the National Park Service at Harpers Ferry.
这在约翰·布朗的突袭中非常重要。今天，在街对面，大约一百英尺远，靠着一栋大砖房的侧面，是另一个纪念碑。老实说，那个纪念碑看起来像一块大墓碑，大约冰箱大小。这是一块刻有文字的大理石纪念碑。这是托德·博尔顿。他在哈珀斯费里的国家公园管理局工作。
Two of our producers, Eric Menel and Nale Besson Stein, talked to him when they visited the town. And the monument he's describing was dedicated to 1931, in honor of the first person killed in John Brown's raid, a man by the name of Hayward Shepherd. There's no images on it, no bronze, it's text, and it's like what, six, four maybe? It's best how old you are.
我们的两位制作人埃里克·梅内尔和内尔·贝松·斯坦在参观该镇时采访了他。他所描述的纪念碑于1931年揭幕，为了纪念约翰·布朗突袭中被杀的第一个人，一个名叫海沃德·谢泼德的人。上面没有图像，没有青铜，只有文字，大概有多高呢，六尺四寸吧？取决于你多大。
That's in good shape. It really is. It's for a hunk of rock, yeah. Hunk of rock, it's in pretty good shape. The interesting thing about Hayward Shepherd isn't just that he was the first person killed by Brown and his raiders. It's that Hayward Shepard was African American, a free black man, a fact that has made this
状态很好。真的很好。对于一块大石头来说，是的。大石头，状态相当不错。关于海沃德·谢泼德有趣的地方不仅在于他是第一个被布朗及其突袭者杀死的人。还在于海沃德·谢泼德是一名非裔美国人，一个获得自由的黑人，这个事实使得这个
memorial more than a little problematic over the years. Eric and Nell tell the story. Hayward Shepard worked as a porter for the B&O railroad in Harper's Ferry. He was on duty the night of October 19, 1859, the night of John Brown's raid. Aware of a commotion outside, Shepard took his lantern and walked down to the train. Brown and company were on their way into town. It was dark, and Shepard was in their path. Either Brown himself or one of his men shot Shepard, leaving him badly injured.
纪念碑多年来多多少少有些问题。埃里克和内尔讲述了这个故事。海沃德·谢泼德在哈珀斯费里的巴尔的摩与俄亥俄铁路公司担任搬运工。1859年10月19日晚上，即约翰·布朗突袭的那天晚上，他正在值班。听到外面有骚动，谢泼德拿着提灯走到火车旁。布朗一行人正在进城。天很黑，谢泼德正好挡在他们的路上。要么是布朗本人，要么是他的一个人开枪击中了谢泼德，导致他重伤。
He died shortly after. Now, Heyward Shepard's name might have been forgotten, had it not been for the efforts of two groups. The United Daughters of the Confederacy and the Sons of Confederate Veterans, the UDC and the SCV. They are run by the descendants of Confederate soldiers and their job is to preserve Confederate heritage, memorials, flags, archives, that kind of stuff. In 1931, the local chapters of the UDC and the SCV erected a memorial to Hayward Shepherd in Harper's Ferry. They placed it directly across the street from the John Brown obelisk.
他不久后去世了。现在，海沃德·谢泼德的名字本来可能会被遗忘，如果不是两个集团的努力的话。联合南方同盟女儿会和南方同盟退伍军人儿子会，简称UDC和SCV。它们由南方同盟士兵的后代运营，他们的工作是保护南方同盟的传统、纪念碑、旗帜、档案之类的事情。1931年，UDC和SCV的地方分会在哈珀斯费里竖立了一座纪念海沃德·谢泼德的纪念碑。他们把它放在正对约翰·布朗方尖碑的街对面。
In one long sentence, the memorial reads, this boulder is set up by the sons of Confederate veterans and the United Daughters of the Confederacy as a memorial to Hayward Shepherd exemplifying the character and faithfulness of thousands of Negroes who, under many temptations throughout the subsequent years of war, so conducted themselves that no stain was left upon a record, which is the peculiar heritage of the American people, and an everlasting tribute
纪念碑在一句长长的句子中写道：这块巨石由南方同盟退伍军人儿子会和联合南方同盟女儿会设立，作为对海沃德·谢泼德的纪念，他体现了成千上万黑人的品格和忠诚，他们在随后多年的战争中，面对种种诱惑，表现得如此得体，没有在属于美国人民特有遗产的纪录上留下任何污点，这是对
to the best in both races. Okay, so to translate that from Monument Speak, we, the SCV and the UDC would like to honor Hayward Shepard and all the other black people in the South who were good and faithful to their white superiors, never rebelling against them or the status quo. The groups had a nickname for this monument. The Faithful Slave Memorial. The Faithful Slave was an idea Confederate heritage groups have been pushing for years. The logic was, since most slaves didn't rebele, they must have been happy.
双方最好品质的永恒敬意。
And if they were happy, it's because their masters treated them well. Slaves were faithful because they knew slavery was better than any other situation available to them. Of course, Hayward Shepard wasn't a slave, so even if there were such a thing as a faithful slave, Shepard wouldn't have fit the bill. But that was no matter. The monument was built and dedicated with plenty of fanfare and plenty of controversy. W.E.B. Du Bois called the dedication a quote, pro-slavery celebration.
好的，将其从“纪念碑语言”翻译过来就是：我们，SCV和UDC想要纪念海沃德·谢泼德以及南方所有对白人上司善良且忠诚的其他黑人，他们从未反抗过白人或现状。这些团体给这座纪念碑起了一个绰号：“忠诚奴隶纪念碑”。“忠诚奴隶”是南方同盟传统团体多年来一直在推崇的一个观点。其逻辑是，既然大多数奴隶没有起义，他们一定很开心。
For 40 years, the monument stood undisturbed. During that time, the National Park Service acquired a bunch of the land and artifacts in Arpers' Ferry, including the Hayward Shepard Memorial and all the problems attached to it. Then, in the 1970s, the park service began restoring some of the old buildings in town. In order to keep the memorial from being damaged, they put it away in a maintenance yard or it stayed for five years. When they put it back in its original location, they made one notable change.
如果他们开心，那是因为他们的主人对他们很好。奴隶们忠诚是因为他们知道奴隶制比他们面临的任何其他处境都好。当然，海沃德·谢泼德并不是奴隶，所以即使真的存在“忠诚奴隶”这种东西，谢泼德也够不上标准。但这没关系。这座纪念碑在阵阵声势和重重争议中建造并揭幕。W·E·B·杜波依斯将这次揭幕仪式称之为“亲奴隶制庆典”。
It was covered with a wooden box. This is Elliott Cummings, former commander of the Sons of Confederate Veterans in the nearby Maryland Division. Remember, the SCV is one of the two groups who originally funded the memorial, so needless to say, they were upset when they found out it had been covered. Todd Bolton, the park service employee, says he wasn't at the top level of memorial discussions, but he had a sense of why certain decisions were being made. My understanding was that there had been the park had had some threats of violence or
四十年来，这座纪念碑一直安然无恙。在此期间，国家公园管理局获得了哈珀斯费里的一批土地和文物，包括海沃德·谢泼德纪念碑以及与之相关的所有问题。然后，在20世纪70年代，公园管理局开始修复镇上的一些老建筑。为了防止纪念碑受损，他们把它收进了一个维护场里，在那里呆了五年。当他们把它放回原位时，他们做了一个显着的改变。
defacing of the monument. So it stayed in storage for some years. By in storage you mean covered or you were covered. There was a shell over it. So the wooden box was painted brown to make it blended in with the trash can covers. Again, Elliot Cummings. So it is concerned me that a legitimate monument at a National Park Service would be covered up in that manner. We kind of worked from there. In the early 90s, Cummings, the sons of Confederate veterans member, began a letter writing campaign to get the box removed. I wrote to Bruce Babitt, who at the time was Secretary of the Interior
它被一个木箱子盖住了。这是埃利奥特·卡明斯，附近马里兰州分会的南方同盟退伍军人儿子会前指挥官。记住，SCV是最初资助这座纪念碑的两个团体之一，所以不用说，当他们发现它被盖住时，他们很不高兴。公园管理局员工托德·博尔顿说，他没有参与纪念碑讨论的最高层，但他对为什么会做出某些决定有所了解。我的理解是，公园曾接到一些暴力威胁或
on your Bill Clinton. I wrote to center of Bird, who was the senior center from West Virginia where Harper's phrase located. In 1995, enough political pressure mounted to force the park service to uncover the memorial. But they added a little something of their own. About 10 feet to the right of the memorial is a small interpretive plaque explaining who Hayward Jeepard was,
对纪念碑进行玷污的威胁。所以它在仓库里存放了几年。你说的存放是指盖着或者你被盖住了。上面有一个外壳。所以木箱被漆成棕色，以便与垃圾桶盖融为一体。再次是埃利奥特·卡明斯。因此，国家公园里的一座合法纪念碑以这种方式被遮盖起来，这让我感到担忧。我们基本上就是从那里开始着手的。在90年代初，身为南方同盟退伍军人儿子会成员的卡明斯发起了一场写信运动，要求撤掉这个箱子。我写信给布鲁斯·巴比特，他当时是内政部长
and what the 1931 controversy was all about. It also offers a quote from W.E.B. Du Bois. Quote, here John Brown aimed at human history a blow that woke a guilty nation, with him fought seven slaves and sons of slaves. The quote was on about John Brown, but mentions neither Hayward Shepard nor the idea of the faithful slave. This is Jim Tolbert, former president of the West Virginia and WACP. He said that he and other members of the NAACP are upset that the plaque doesn't adequately debunk
在比尔·克林顿手下。我写信给伯德参议员，他是哈珀斯费里所在的西弗吉尼亚州的资深参议员。1995年，足够的政治压力迫使公园管理局揭开了纪念碑的面纱。但他们加上了一点他们自己的东西。在纪念碑右侧大约10英尺处，有一块小型解说牌，解释了海沃德·谢泼德是谁，
the faithful slave narrative, or as he puts it. That is clearly a lie. And I'll just keep on calling it a lie. It's a lie. And while the NAACP thought the plaque said too little, the sons of Confederate veterans were unhappy. It was there at all. We're not happy that they felt the need to put an interpretive plaque next to it.
以及1931年的争议是怎么回事。它还引用了W·E·B·杜波依斯的一句话。引文：在这里，约翰·布朗向人类历史投下了一击，唤醒了一个有罪的国家，与他并肩作战的有七名奴隶和奴隶的儿子。这句话是关于约翰·布朗的，但既没有提到海沃德·谢泼德，也没有提到忠诚奴隶的概念。这是吉姆·托尔伯特，西弗吉尼亚州全国有色人种协进会前主席。他说，他和全国有色人种协进会的其他成员对这块牌匾未能充分揭穿
We feel that the Starko monument stands on their own. That is our job. Our job is not to tell you to come here, and this is what we want you to think about this particular part of history. We don't do that. Our job is to present the history, to show balanced perspectives and allow you as an individual to based on that unbiased information, to walk away with your own with your own conclusions. Today, the NAACP is still pretty upset about the whole situation but there's only so much they can do
忠诚奴隶的叙事感到不满，或者正如他所说的那样。这显然是个谎言。我会一直称之为谎言。这是一个谎言。虽然全国有色人种协进会认为这块牌匾说得太少，但南方同盟退伍军人儿子会却很不高兴。它根本就不该在那里。我们对他们觉得有必要在旁边放一块解说牌感到很不高兴。
the Confederate heritage groups would get rid of the plaque in a heartbeat but they've more or less moved on the park service maintains that the memorial is an historical artifact entrusted to the US government and will continue to maintain it as such. The Hayward Shepherd Memorial may have just been a monument to a particular vision of this south, but it does point to something else. Over the past 150 years, there has been little effort to memorialize slavery in a way that reflects the true scale of the experience and its reverberations. What's clear is that slavery can't be stored in a maintenance yard or covered up with a plywood box. And one has to wonder if there will ever be an interpretive plaque big enough to make sense of it all.
我们认为这座孤立的纪念碑可以靠自身立足。那是我们的工作。我们的工作不是告诉你来这里，这就是我们希望你对这段特定历史的看法。我们不这样做。我们的工作是呈现历史，展示平衡的观点，并允许你作为个人，根据这些公正的信息，得出你自己的结论。今天，全国有色人种协进会仍然对整个情况感到非常不满，但他们能做的事情有限
Eric Mittle and Nail Besson Stein are producers for backstory. For pictures of the Haywood Shepherd Memorial and more about its origins, visit backstoryradio.org. That's a story from the Monuments episode of backstory with the American History Guys. I'll have a link on our website to their show and you should subscribe because you're really going to like it. 99% invisible is me Roman Mars and Sam Greenspan. We are a project of KAA, HLW, 91.7, the local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars.
南方同盟传统团体恨不得立刻除掉这块牌匾，但他们基本上已经向前看了。公园管理局坚称，这座纪念碑是托付给美国政府的历史文物，并将继续像以前一样维护它。海沃德·谢泼德纪念碑可能只是南方特定愿景的一座纪念碑，但它确实指出了其他东西。在过去的150年里，几乎没有付出什么努力来以一种反映真实经验规模及其回响的方式来纪念奴隶制。显而易见的是，奴隶制不能被存放在维护场里，也不能用胶合板箱遮盖起来。人们不禁要问，是否会有一块足够大的解说牌来理清这一切。
And if you live in the Bay Area and enjoy pizza and repetitive tasks, they have no real need to get paid. Well, then maybe you should get in touch. RomanatPRX.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
埃里克·米特尔和内尔·贝松·斯坦是Backstory的制作人。有关海沃德·谢泼德纪念碑的照片及其起源的更多信息，请访问backstoryradio.org. 这是来自美国历史老爹们的Backstory节目中“纪念碑”一集的报道。我会在我们的网站上提供他们节目的链接，你应该订阅，因为你真的会喜欢它。99% Invisible由我罗曼·马尔斯和萨姆·格林斯潘制作。我们是旧金山当地公共广播电台KAA，HLW，91.7以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我在推特上的账号是Roman Mars。